hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for Hunter again and
yesterday was the end of season 12
campaign now we're heading into the
offseason where we can get a lot of
juicy info coming up on year four and
what the faction war is gonna look like
the new heroes coming in the future as
well as the battle pass and a lot of
other things but that isn't today's
topic at the moment today's topic is
gonna be about what those season twelve
fashion Awards are who won and what they
look like in game so as always like the
V if you do enjoy a subscribe for new I
covered the informational side a
foreigner that being the belts changes
to hear updates the passwords and the
leaks if you wanna be kept up to date
with everything happening within the
world the foreigner I never miss out on
an update that we subscribe to channel
and with that let's get started with
today's video to let you know some of
the rewards if you're a new player the
Vikings if you're part of the Viking
faction you get everything we're going
to be showing here since I am also on a
Viking account so everything that I'm
getting is exactly what yours are
Samurai you're going to be getting the
outline and the emblem but not the
ornaments and the Knights you're only
going to be getting the outline as
always we're going to be starting off
with the ornaments that these are going
to be faction based meaning they're
going to look different perfection some
ornaments look the same throughout every
character some of them are hero based so
they look different per character this
is going to be perfection so all Knights
are going to have the exact same all the
Vikings the samurai and the Wulin will
have their own and like I said this is
only for players who are part of the
Viking faction you're gonna be called
kealan trophy like I said it's unlocked
by winning the season twelve faction
more and as you can see there's a lot of
cool designs the very thing in the
middle that's red that is actually my
color so that is going to be one of the
things that you can customize on your
ornament to match the color I know
they've added that and an update like
almost a year ago now so that is that
middle part that you can customize make
it blue make it purple
all depending on what your regular armor
color is it's honestly not too bad
there's a lot of curves a lot of
different really intricate designs
throughout the middle of the piece and
but in my opinion this really doesn't
belong on the head we'll get to a little
bit later why I say that but just in my
opinion this isn't actually the too bad
I'm an ornament though I think at least
in my taste some of the characters that
I play they have a lot better ornaments
that I could be utilizing next up we had
the Vikings and it also has that red
piece in the middle which you can
customize it has the typical Viking
style that you would see in ornaments
and styles of that
of nature with all those lines drawn in
the middle of the designs I have no clue
what they're called
I just always notice that they're always
representative of the Viking kind of
culture in terms of size it seems like
it's a little bit smaller than the
Knights one which honestly might not be
a bad idea if you want to go for some
smaller looking ornaments overall not
too bad specifically on shaman I
actually don't think this is a bad pick
but in my opinion I feel like she might
be one of the few characters on the
Vikings that can actually kind of look
good with this ornament next up we have
the samurai and he toki rehear is going
to be showing off what they look like on
the shoulder pads and this is what I
meant by I really think that this is not
really for the helmet I really think
this is going to benefit the year three
heroes your man Gunther black prior heat
so kiri soon died because they have the
availability to put ornaments on their
shoulders I think this is going to look
really nice on the shoulder pads because
the head you know it's a very small area
and those things are pretty big
especially with the samurai one going
super up at this curve so honestly think
the shoulder pads is gonna look really
nice so if you have any of the year
three characters definitely look at them
first for the ornament and then go to
the other characters to test it out yeah
as you could see the middle part once
again is going to be colorized as it is
simplified in blue and then there's a
bunch of other designs on the outside
with a very booking Sun on the top as
well and then next up we're gonna have
new Shoshone what the woolen one is I'm
not gonna do like soon dive for the
woolen just because I wanted you to see
on that one character what the shoulder
piece looks like and it's a lot easier
to see the full design and when it's on
the head based off of when it's on the
shoulder so for new show she has this
giant piece in terms of the comparison
between the other characters I don't
actually think this is the biggest one
it seems like it's rivaling the Knights
though in terms of size so it seems like
the Vikings have the smallest ornament
which I believe the samurai having the
biggest one thanks to those two giant
spikes that curved and once again the
middle as usual is going to be the
center piece and that's going to be
colorized depending on the color of your
armor this one has a lot more flames
that I noticed that's kind of actually
similar to the Knights one just a little
bit more thicker on the Knights ornament
other than that not a bad ornament piece
but like I said I might actually pick
this up if I use it on soon da so
because I prefer to see them on the
shoulders as opposed to the headpiece so
that was only for the Viking faction
players but this is going to be for the
Viking and Samurai
because both of you guys had hit first
and second place and you're going to be
getting the key landmark which is the
emblem of this season it's not really
that great in Tiana B I probably could
have picked a better character to
showcase this but I think you get the
understanding of the design once again
I'm not really sure this is going to
match with like a chess piece I'm
thinking maybe a shoulder piece could
fit fit with this maybe somewhere on the
helmet could work too but it's totally
up to you now lastly we have the outline
and if you're new to the game let me try
to summarize this the gold at the bottom
is going to be the only thing that
changes so the outline you know if being
a circle of course is going to change
depending on the dimensions of your
faction but that purple and that steel
and the throughout the whole piece is
going to be staying the gold will be
changing because I'm a Viking and the
Vikings won the faction war their colors
in gold if you're a samurai yours is
going to be in silver because you came
in second and if you're in Knight years
will be in bronze color if you are a
Knights because you went in third place
this is going to think through every
single faction more I just have to
clarify because we do get new players
all the time and I just want to make
sure that they're caught up to date with
that stuff but yes I've been talking
you've been looking at the piece of this
outline and honestly it's not too bad I
think it fits depending on what type of
style you want to go for me playing a
lot of soon now having an all purple
character I think having this purple
shield to kind of match it is really
cool especially with the gold at the
bottom I think that's really stellar
well once again this is just an outline
there really isn't much to do with this
kind of thing it just kind of look
little flashy maybe put it on your
character on that small chance but
usually you kind of just have it on your
outline and that's really it and
honestly I don't think it looks too bad
yeah guys that's gonna be the end of the
vid say I hope you guys did enjoy let me
know what you guys think if I had to
give my top list of the ornaments I'd
probably give the Wulin one as like a
the first one I think the Vikings in my
opinion are a little bit too small for
my taste so I'm gonna have to put them
in fourth not because the Viking one is
terrible of course that one is really
good I just like really big flashy
ornaments like all the samurai have
pretty much so I've always been a big
fan of that so any big ornament always
gonna be a favorite for me yeah let me
know your favorite ornament in your
least favorite ornament in the comments
below you already know the deal two
comments YouTube algorithm appreciate
that ahead of time yeah I'd like to be
if you do enjoy subscribe but for new I
cover the informational side of
foreigner that being the balance changes
the here updates the patch notes and the
leaks
if when we kept up today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
I never miss out on an update
Duffey stay subscribe the channel I
guess take care have a great is today
peace out
[Music]